[Music]
[Applause]
uh Albert Breer is back with us Albert
thanks for uh having the patience here
for us uh let's go back to Lamar Jackson
you don't think that it it was
calculated you think it was just
coincidental
no I think it was calculated like I mean
I I I think you know Dan if you're if
you're Lamar and you've been hearing for
you know six weeks now how you're
stumbling around and you have no idea
what you're doing and you need to hire
an agent like if you have to hear all
that over and over and over again how
you're messing this whole thing up and
blowing all this money like you might
want to do something to send a message
right and you might want to do something
that's cold and cunning and calculating
like a team would do right so like just
to set the scene for you yesterday
um it was about 7 45 a.m local time the
John Harbaugh sat down at his table with
the media around him and obviously
because of the situation he's got a big
crowd
I think it was about 90 seconds after
that that Lamar Jackson uh sent that
tweet out and if you think about it like
the trade request didn't just go in it
went in over three weeks ago so is it
coincidental that it's happening in this
one hour went no you know what I mean
like John Harbaugh is sitting there for
actually in an hour and a half hour with
the media and 90 seconds into that half
hour he hit send on the Tweet so but
what purpose does it serve though Albert
it sends a message I mean it makes like
the whole thing is like you know I feel
like a lot of times in these situations
the way teams make players uncomfortable
is they sit there and do nothing and
they say eventually you're going to
squirm and eventually you're gonna move
it's a negotiating tactics so if they're
trying to make you feel uncomfortable
well then it's on you to make them feel
uncomfortable back you know and so I I
do think that this was an effort to turn
up the heat on on the Ravens by Lamar
Jackson and his camp and it's a very
very small circle so um and I I actually
look at it like that was probably a
smart thing to do like from a
negotiating standpoint that's what a
team would do to a player right like
they would do something to make the
player feel uncomfortable if they felt
like the player had the advantage in
that situation and so I guess after
three months so if they're not being you
know enough movement and you know we
we've all heard about what's happened
over the last week with you know an
advisor for Lamar's calling around to
teams and I can verify that's happened
um you know I I think it's just got to
the point where Lamar felt like he had
to do something to turn the heat up on
the Ravens this I think was a pretty
smart way to do it okay do you have to
give up two first round picks is is this
negotiable if let's say the Colts go we
want Lamar Jackson
uh can we give you a first and a third
and we're gonna pay him whatever we're
going to pay him
I mean you could if you want to talk to
the Ravens you could you could go to the
Ravens and ask for that but if you do
that before the draft aren't the Ravens
going to ask for the fourth pick sure
like the smart move and I think the
Colts are one of the teams in the top 10
that could consider this and I'm either
other teams that maybe should consider
this that are in the top ten like who
there's no there's no like if you're I
mean I I know Atlanta's not going to do
it but should they consider it they
should look at it you know here's the
thing right here's the thing right like
if you're one of these teams if you're
Indianapolis and you're saying to
yourself we want to go through the full
process with the quarterbacks and I can
tell you for a fact like when Chicago
called them about you know dealing the
first pick and they had some discussion
on it the Colts weren't there on the
quarterbacks yet they weren't there with
one of the quarterbacks yet so like I
think it stands to reason that they're
not going to be comfortable with whoever
follows them before so if you're the
coals you don't want to give up the
fourth pick for Lamar what do you do
what you can do is you could wait until
after the draft you could use the fourth
pick on I don't know will Anderson you
know a great defensive player and then
get past the draft you know but by the
way when you get past the draft you're
not talking about the fourth pick
anymore you're talking about 2024 first
round pick in a 2025 first round pick
and if you still think Lamar's a great
player like he has been the first five
years of his career and you can find a
way to stand it keeping healthy like we
could be talking about the 25th pick in
the draft next year you know what I mean
like so it's no longer the fourth pick
so I I think that there are teams in the
top ten that are not comfortable with
this group of quarterbacks with the with
the the four quarterbacks who are you
know expected to go in the first round
and they really might not be comfortable
with the quarterbacks that fall to them
wherever they're picking inside the top
ten so this could be an alternative
where you can use your top 10 pick on
another player if you're willing to wait
and then sign Lamar Jackson to an offer
sheet after the draft where you wouldn't
be spending this year's pick you'd be
spending picks over the next two years
which you know you'd figure if Lamar
Jackson is on your team it'd be a much
lower pick than the one you have you
have this year what about the Patriots
it's a lot of fun isn't it but they're
irrelevant I mean they they don't have
anything there there there's no juice
whatsoever and Belichick's talking about
what happened you know the last 25 years
hey you know moving for this guy never
talks about what's in the rear view
mirror but if you want to kiss what I
know okay
well here's usually here's what I know
Dan like bill has had opportunity after
opportunity to like get Mac Jones is
back over the last six months going all
the way back to the Bailey's happy thing
in October and the way that thing blew
up
he hasn't done it like it's constantly
been you know he hasn't declared him a
starter he when he's asked about there
being a competition between Jones and
zappy he says well you know like all
things are sort of open every position
is open he he's had opportunity after
opportunity to back Mac Jones and he
hasn't done it and then the owner comes
out and publicly speaks about Lamar
Jackson yesterday in the whole Meek Mill
thing and everything else
like what I like what I know about Bill
is he loves players like this that like
the reason he went and got Randy Moss is
because he couldn't find another one of
them and if you think about how bill
came up
that's what Lawrence Taylor was like and
if you've ever heard Bill and Dan I'm
sure you've heard Bill talk about
Lawrence Taylor right yeah I mean it's
like he's talking about Michael Jordan
when he just like talks about who he was
as a player and everything else
Lamar's sort of that way now I'm not
saying Lamar's Lawrence Taylor and like
is going to go down with that sort of
Legacy but when you're talking about
just how unique he is and how different
he is and how if your bill you create so
much stress in the opponent with this
one player like I think that that all
appeals to him and the idea of what he
could do creatively maybe in his last
act as an NFL head coach all of it lines
up now do I think it's going to happen
probably not but it's a fun idea and
it's one that like like you look at it
like yesterday again this just like Bill
had the opportunity and has had the
opportunity to declare Mac Jones his
starter over the last six months and
didn't do it he also had the chance and
Robert crafted too to shoot the Lamar
Jackson thing out of the sky yesterday
and neither of them did that either he's
Albert Breer the senior NFL reporter
Monday Morning Quarterback what did what
are the Packers saying here what is
Brian gudacon's trying to tell us with
Aaron Rodgers
I think that they're sick and tired of
this whole thing I mean I think you can
hear it in gudacon's voice
um you know I like I I had a feeling it
might go this way and it would turn into
Aaron says one thing happened the
Packers say another thing happened and
who knows where the you know who knows
what the truth is but what it really
reveals is How deep the wounds are here
right between the two sides and I I go
back to like what happened a couple
years ago and you remember the press
conference when you know Aaron showed up
um at the beginning of training camp
right and he got up there and I think it
went on like a 20-minute monologue and
basically like detailed everything and
like there were there was a lot of I
would say dirty laundry aired there well
the Packers had no idea that was going
to happen the Packers thought that
everything had been settled and okay
we're good we're in lockstep we're
moving forward and I know there are
people in the Packers organization that
were stunned when that went down
they swallowed it last year what did
they do for him they said okay we're
gonna Aaron we're gonna leave the light
on for you take your time make your
decision do everything you need to do
and we're here for you we want you as
our quarterback
you know I just think that there's a
fatigue there for the Packers on like
like with bending over backwards over
the last couple of years to accommodate
him and now even on the way out like he
does this it's like his last act as a
packer is like I I it feels like kind of
pointing the finger back at the
organization like this is why this is
happening so
um yeah I think you see how deep the
wounds are here and you know I I think
Aaron actually probably could have made
it easier on himself if he had just gone
on McAfee a couple weeks ago and said
you know what
and look it's great content I'm not
telling anybody not to to do what Aaron
did but this is great for all of us good
for business I'm sure for you guys too
but um you know like I think like if
Aaron's like singular goal was to get
himself to the Jets he could have said
look I appreciate everything that Brian
goodacons to Matt leflore and
um and Mark Murphy have done for me over
the last couple years it didn't work out
but I'll have great memories of it and
and I think it's just time for everybody
to move on
I think that this is the tone antenna
this is a lot different and I think that
I actually think that he's probably on
the Jets now
um and so I think cooler heads will
eventually Prevail but you know I think
part of this is you know the pack is
sort of cleaning up everything the the
mess of the last couple of weeks and
then trying to get you know the best
value they can for him and I think you
started to see yesterday them coming off
their positions just a little bit and
saying maybe we don't need to insist on
the 13th overall pick
most interesting possible rule change is
what
the gambling one I think you know and
and this isn't an on-field rule change
but the gambling one's really
interesting to me um for those who don't
know
um they're going to allow Sports books
and savings of voting on it um they're
going to allow Sports books and stadiums
um to operate on game day which I mean
given that we can all do this on our
phones now it doesn't seem like a big
deal but if you told me that there'd be
a sports book and you know whatever 20
NFL stadiums in 2023 10 years ago my jaw
would hit the floor you know what I mean
like so I think from a Global
Perspective and just kind of the
business of the game and everything else
that's probably the biggest rule change
um as far as the on-field stuff I I
think the continued elimination of the
punt and kickoff is probably the biggest
one you know what I mean like I had Mike
westoff and you know Westy coached you
know he's back with the Broncos now but
his coach special teams in the league
going back to like the mid 80s he gave
me this number that was just incredible
um he said that over his first 30 years
in the NFL there were an average of I
think it was 22 specialty games plays
excluding extra points and field goals
per game he said by the time he got to
his last year at the Saints which I
believe was 2018 that number was down to
seven so you know you think about like
how that changes the way the game is
played that changes the way that rosters
are made up like the value of special
teams players I mean think about this
Dan like how long it wasn't that long
ago that like some of the biggest stars
in the game were kick returners Dante
Hall Devin Hester how many kick
returners can you name right now Cordero
Patterson I think right right and and
Keyshawn uh Nixon from the Packers is
the other one and I I think I just
learned his name last year but how do we
get rid of the punt
I well I think that they're going to
continue to uh I would say incentivize
Fair catches
um and I like their injury data is that
and this is all health and safety stuff
obviously but their injury data shows
that like there's a higher likelihood
you know of high-end collisions and
injuries resulting from them on kickoffs
and punts punts are a little more
difficult I would say to eliminate
um you know but I do think that that's
um you know I I do think finding ways to
incentivize
um just non-returns I think is the way
to is is the way that they're going to
do it you know and then even like the
on-site kick you know and I don't think
this rule proposal is going to pass but
I'm sure you've seen it Philly's rule
proposal yeah that in lieu of the onside
kick I think you do like I think I think
this year they proposed a fourth and 20
from the 20.
which is a really interesting fun idea
um but I just feel like it sort of
bastardizes what football's always been
so I know for a lot of the coaches that
you know are involved in these things is
trying to strike the balance between
prioritizing the health and safety part
of it while also trying to preserve what
the the makeup of the game is and again
again like you know these sorts of rules
changes can affect who has jobs and who
doesn't you know what I mean like it
could affect like how much a special
teams coach makes it can affect the
bottom you have 13 guys in your roster
what do those guys look like all those
sorts of things are impacted by this
okay the most interesting Lobby rumor
not story rumor do you got one
um
yeah I
just trying to think
Lobby rumor
God that's a tough one see I'm trying to
think of what I can share
um
you know I like I think
I think the way the top of the draft
shakes out
um to me is really really interesting
now and I would say t I would say the
Divide between Bryce young and CJ Stroud
and then will love us and Anthony
Richardson is a little bigger than most
people think when you're talking about
like the general consensus of the NFL
and so I think Stroud and young and some
were go one and two I think the other
things like how special young is as a
player like you sort of hear that too
um but I think Stroud and young go one
two in some order and then I think it's
sort of up in the air because I do think
that there are teams in the top ten that
aren't wild about this quarterback class
and again like what makes it so
interesting is the idea that some team
in the top ten could feel that way about
the quarterback class and then turn
around after the draft and roll the dice
and sign Lamar Jackson do an offer sheet
even though there is the risk that the
Ravens could just match and you wouldn't
wind up with a player I was looking for
something more salacious than that I'm
just trying to think I mean I come on
just make something up you know
[Laughter]
hey uh great great to talk to you as
always ask me you know what you know
what Dan like next time I'm on ask me
and I'll have it have had a chance to
process everything and I'll I'll I'll
have something better
that's a crappy room it was you're such
a great journalist that you don't deal
with rumor and innuendo well I mean
there are a couple of things but it's
like I can't really talk about that I
can't really how about With No Name
no name no no team
yeah I would say
um
I don't want to get you in trouble
I don't want to I don't want to get you
in trouble
yeah I would uh
just come back to me okay all right
I thought about that when I thought
about that you put that on the table I'm
like yeah no no no
it'd be like a page six like blind item
or whatever oh okay yeah all right so
Tom Brady dating is that what you're
talking about
yeah I I uh Tom Brady Las Vegas Raider
by the end of the year next year we'll
see thank you Albert that's uh all right
Albert Brewer the Monday Morning
Quarterback I don't get him in trouble
he's such a nice guy